qu'est ce que vous dites déjà ça moi je
suis bêtement tweet à moi parce que jean
luc mélenchon n'est quand même pas mon
porte parole
non mais moi je commençais par mélenchon
alors on va voir mais
moi je vais le faire je vais le faire
encadrer nous l'eau le soi disant bon
alors on va passer sur leurs torts a
faim c'est pas son truc
alors perte de sens pour l'émission
alors raquel garrido lui tient tête et
pour cela elle est évincé du plateau de
ballons se pose donc en fait ni jean-luc
mélenchon ni raquel garrido ne savent
que je ne suis en charge ni débat ni des
débatteurs une choisi sérail des ballons
surtout je pense tout à responsabiliser
suis d'accord avec et alors c'est une
idée des batteurs alors c'est ça c'est
pas lui qui fait la table je le dis
voilà comme ça je voudrais raconter les
coulisses de cette émission eric ne fait
pas la table c'est pas lui qui choisit
les personnes qui vont être autour de la
table et c'est vrai qu'il nous l'a
jamais demandé je fais le vêtement
twitter atelier janvier la turquie
reconnaît il c'est possible j'aimerais
qu'on me respecte comme on va te
remettes après mais je suis wallon
mélenchon
tweet après tweets mais c'est dingue
mais des réserves dans la gueule c'est
donc autant mais on
n'aura pas beaucoup de temps alors donc
déjà vous vous ignorez que je n'ai
jamais demandé qu un débatteur soient
présents ou absents je parle encore sous
la responsabilité de cyril je ne suis
jamais intervenu adieu le pluralisme il
se trouve qu'il y avait un autre
représentant de la france insoumis ce
qu'était eric coquerel le pluralisme et
est respecté il y avait des gens de
droite des gens de gauche il y avait un
représentant de la france insoumise
naulleau animateurs militant dit qu'il
voterait et moore pour bloquer mélenchon
sait pas ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'en
cas de 2e tour zemmour mélenchon je
voterai pour zemmour je ne cherche pas à
bloquer mélenchon parce qu'il n'arrivera
pas au deuxième tour donc c'est quelque
chose de très hypothétique mais le plus
beau de la faire c'est que le tweet est
signée jean luc mélenchon qui quand il a
été invité à balances ton post a exigé
que je sois absent à exiger mon éviction
c'est à dire que celui qui se dresse
contre la censure et celui qui a exercé
la censure contre moi et moi pour moi ce
que ce tweet est un sommet comique
j'hésite même à le commenter parce que
pour pour moi ça vient d'un rigolo voilà
alors on va voir le tweet de raquette
maintenant le tube bracket je suis au
regret de vous annoncer que je ne serai
pas dans ma loge son poste ce soir
j'avais demandé un changement de
comportement suite aux tensions entre
eric naulleau et moi la prod m'a informé
les conditions de la présence à
l'émission n'étaient pas réunies pour ce
soir alors qu'elle ouvrait revenir sur
ce twitt dis nous ce que tu as voulu
expliquer voilà là dedans et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je vais tous les
téléspectateurs de balances ton post
l'ont constaté comme comme moi comme
tout le monde comme toujours vous voulez
qu'on voit les images ah ben si vous les
avez préparé tout alors on va refaire
déjà toute l'histoire raquel garrido
eric zemmour et eric naulleau c'est vrai
mais la fumée noire et à chaque fois tu
fais ça pour remonter au premier clash
entre eric naulleau et raquel garrido il
faut tout simplement remonter à la
première de raquel dans btp c'était le
12 septembre 2019 ils ont eu leurs
premières tensions regardez
les noms c'est culturel il faut la
combattre
mélenchon qui chouine toute la journée
devant la caméra j'ai une perquisition
et ya trop de pathos de l'autre côté
mais la france insoumise vous êtes un
pays a vraiment
d'arriver avec un maquereau nist ah bon
voila tu adores et moi que je lui dis
c'est pas qu'on comptera plus que tu
viendras valeur moi t'as quoi comme
preuve à l'appui de ce que tu dis moi je
suis ma croix
avec les insoumis j'ai quelques preuves
en effet et c'est assez bien dans des
rapports comment cela s'est bien
documenté que le fait pas mais les
maires actuels acat-france insoumise ils
sont comment alors ça c'était le premier
ensuite quelques mois plus tard lors
d'une émission consacrée à la détente
des retraites raquel elle était très
présent pendant l'émission elle était à
et et été remontés et sa mis hors de lui
eric qui a eu des mots assez durs
contreras quel regard des as et les feux
de l'amour rt par super accueil raquel
garrido en pourcentage cariou et
laissées par les riques naulleau qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous de manger une
question est ce que la pénibilité inclut
des acouphènes d'abord c'est pas parce
que tu prend un air supérieur que ça
fait quelqu'un de toi quelqu'un de cela
desservi la cause rac alors j'avais la
côte gens qui regardent quelle que
soit l'amitié
foot et dans la démagogie ou thé dans le
terrorisme intellectuel ou à la dérobée
oui aux terminaux de tout le monde s'est
parlé
alors on va revenir sur le gros clash la
semaine dernière ce qu'on va pas tous et
faire ainsi le monde est là jusqu'à pas
d'heure le débat portait sur la laïcité
à l'école et karim zéribi avait du mal à
prendre la parole voilà et déjà voilà et
donc eric on a profité pour tacler
raquette regardez il ya eu voilà il ya
un petit échange entre deux neurones me
chaut
sujet déclaré cette petite façon de vous
toujours vouloir me censurer toujours de
vous la remet à prendre la vie c'est
vous qui m'avez fonction et au moins du
respect pour votre voisin karim zéribi
qui avait commencé comme ça merci
beaucoup moi aussi je voudrais un peu de
respect pour ce que j'ai dans la dans la
tête j'aime en dessous c'est bien le
problème
et toi parce que tu es un misogyne et
j'ai pu lever une femme est alors c'est
bien la preuve karim
personne ne rigole donner des petites
vannes pourries bon
maire émission marche bien vraiment
c'est vrai bravo amour en tout cas ok
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'ils soient je ne
trouve pas que l'émission s'est bien et
d'ailleurs vous noterez que la grande
différence entre les premiers extraits
et le dernier on aurait pu prendre ceux
d'autres depuis le début de la saison
c'est que dans un premier cas eric était
co chroniqueur avec mac os
éditorialistes et donc chacun est dans
son rôle et c'est là la fin là il est
animateur et ça change tout ça change
tout pour les autres animateurs ça
change tout pour les téléspectateurs
moi moi quand j'ai commencé ballon ce
temps poste c'était une émission
vraiment moi j'adorais avec la cua c'est
à dire qu on était une bande zéribi
à
gâteau proue du mime mohamed c'était un
peu united colors of benetton il touche
pas à mon pote c'est un peu touche pas à
mon pote quoi en fait c'était cinespace
où il n'y avait pas d'espacé pour le
racisme y avait pas d espace pour
l'extrême droite etc et progressivement
on jan
subrepticement comme ça il ya un petit
shift et le fait que eric naulleau à
nîmes c'est évidemment pour les
téléspectateurs comme pour nous les
autres chroniques un une différence de
quand c'est toi cyril ça n'a strictement
rien à voir alors lui il
il va être l'anti mélenchon primaire bon
il a le droit donc en tant
qu'intellectuel citoyens d'être anti
mélenchon primaire le problème c'est que
quand il est animateur il faut qu'il
fasse avec tout le tour de table y
compris avec une personne qui
effectivement est proche de la france
finit fiscale pardon excusez moi mais
alors vous êtes aussi quand même être
bien positionné pour donner mon
impression bien sûr que quand tu animé
l'émission mais ces dossiers
exactement et moi avec eric que souvent
on est opposée sur plein d'idées moi je
m'oppose tous les joueurs à zemmour donc
de dire qu'il veut pas d'opposants à
zemmour sur le plateau déjà c'est un
mensonge puisque j étais fière et je
pense que je porte justement mes valeurs
chaque jour contre lui déjà on peut
rétablir sa mais laraque elle tu ne te
rends pas compte le comportement que tu
as commencé dès détestable pour nous
tous parce que tu saccage l'émission je
vais te le dire avec mon coeur la
semaine dernière c'était effroyable
parce que tu t'en prends à lui parce que
ça te gêne qu'ils soient animateurs
peut-être battu d'être à sa place je ne
sais pas tu l'as déjà expliqué et tu ne
peux pas prendre en otage notre émission
à tous on est une équipe tous les gens
qui produisent derrière tous les gens
qui équipe s'occupe de nous et saccagé
l'émission je te jure on ne savait pas
où se mettre parce que tu te les prix
mis en tête et tout à coup ça a été
influent d'accusation c'est un plateau
d'extrême droite on ne parlait que
zemmour et c'est déjà cette mode
toujours commentée pour qu'on vous
choisi un sujet ou l'autre c'est
insupportable c'est pas à nous de dire
pourquoi on soyez un sujet ou l'autre
c'est des sujets d'actualité et ensuite
de dire que parce que tu l'a suggéré là
parce qu'il ya des gens qui sont plus à
droite maintenant sur le plateau et
alors en fait vous êtes pour la censure
à la france insoumise tu dis qu'il
censure mais c'est vous qui censure et
vous voulez pas des gens de droite
voulait pas jean kiffer black blanc beur
bon c'est vrai c'est bon c'est bon
laurence après je vous le dis c'est vrai
qu'aussi et j'aurais peut-être dû vous
en parler à tous les chroniqueurs de btp
c'est vrai que j'aurais dû peut-être
faire une petite réunion en disant voilà
en expliquant que c'est eric elle est
animée voilà je vais revenir dans
balances ton post également jeu en ami
mais je vous dis pas mal des coraux
prendra donc je vais je vais vraiment
animé pas mal de balances ton post aussi
mais c'est vrai que j'aurais peut-être
dû se dire voilà c'est eric qui va
prendre ma place et j'aurais peut-être
bu vous en parlait tous en même temps
voilà c'est peut-être ça aussi c'est pas
ça le fait non mais le fait de masse
éditorialistes animateur principal aussi
voilà peut-être que voilà il y en a qui
l'ont ils n'ont ils ont ils l'ont mal
perçues après dire eric naulleau j'ai su
revenir sur le sujet eric c'est que
voilà ce que vous reprochez eric et
c'est que eric et animateur mais il est
aussi militant pour vous c'est à dire
que ils donnent trop son avis sur les
sujets si son style d'animation qu'est
ce que vous dites ah ça non mais moi
j'aimerais qu'on revenus qu'on revienne
sur le véritable problème le problème on
l'a vu sur les images les des voisins
arakel ils n'en peuvent plus tu vois la
tête de renard et julien courbet tu vois
tu vois la tête de karim zéribi il est
accablé il ya une migraine qui monte il
a fini par te le dire moi j'ai quand
même le souvenir de d'un certain cyril
hanouna qui était animateur il lui
arrivait que tu lui fasse péter les
plombs aussi on a vu des choses je ne
trahis pas des secrets puisque c'était à
moitié en plateau à moitié en dehors du
plateau les gens qui siègent avec toi au
conseil municipal de bagnolet me disent
que c'est la même chose que tu pourri
toutes les réunions auxquelles tu
participes je sais pas pourquoi parce
que tu n'as pas le son jubé bas
certainement parce que tu arrêtes là
mais plusieurs fois ma place donc tu à
la fois juge et partie donc évidemment
quand on réclame la place de quelqu'un
on dit qu'il fait pas bien le boulot ou
alors qu'il est partisan enfin tout ça
est marquée par une grande malhonnêteté
intellectuelle et un refus des règles
élémentaires du débat les règles
élémentaires du débat c'est de laisser
parler les autres de se concentrer sur
le sujet tuer la reine du hors sujet tu
fais du hors sujet comme d'autres font
du hors piste c'est ta passion qui lui
et ça doit être une passion solitaire
c'est le chez toi quand tu es sur un
plateau tu respectes les autres tu
arrêtes de parler constamment et de
hurler à la misogynie j'ai été mise au j
j'ai été émue rien j'ai été macro this
un peu contradictoire tout ça quand même
un tout simplement parce que dès qu'on
n'est pas d'accord avec vous la france
insoumise on est des fascistes on est
ceci et cela c'est insupportable quand
tu es comme dans la vie tu es quelqu'un
de tout à fait fréquentable de tout un
tas d'or a effectué sur un plateau tu
est insupportable et tu pourri cette
émission n'est pas demander si tu veux
ma place gagne là alors oui attendu
après on va on va donner à parlera
quelqu'un oui non j'espère donner
l'extérieur sonné mois mais non avec moi
d'extérieur jeu j'ai trouvé ce moment
très très gênant très mal exemple que
j'ai trouvé eric naulleau en dehors de
son de son personnage de son rôle
d'animateur vraiment méprisant envers
raquel et je pense que sira quelle est
la plus haute en fait aussi pour pour
ses qualités et ses défauts qu'on l'a
choisi sur le plateau alors ce que
l'étude en ce qui me concerne j'en passe
très bien des défauts de requêtes
mathieu quand je pense que alors déjà
écrit à la misogynie ça c'est un truc
qui est pénible aujourd'hui parce que
voilà ça n'a rien à voir débat en
revanche je pense que le problème c'est
que effectivement eric a commencé comme
chroniqueur d'on connaît toutes ces
idées parker et du coup quand il est
animateur animateur c'est quelqu'un qui
n'exprime pas ses idées mais qui donne
la parole et forcément quand tu deviens
animateurs on connaît tes idées donc on
se dit va donner plus à lui plus à lui
je pense que tu devrais être sur un trio
animateurs et éventuellement quand cyril
et animateurs ne pas chroniqueur de
l'émission mais sinon il ya un problème
moi j'ai envie qu'il soit là pour
contourner ces idées du coup quand il
est là on dit que forcément il va
peut-être donner un petit peu plus la
parole qu'à quelqu'un d'autre je sais
pas je dis pas que c'est le cas mais à
chroniqueur ne peut pas être animateur
yu-na qui ne doivent pas donner son avis
et l'autre qui ne fait que donner son
avis bien sûr ce que tu as dit que tu as
dit le truc on se dit que ça il suffit
de pas se dire que il suffit d'écouter
voilà et de loire sfd et de voir si
justement effectivement la répartition
de la parole elle est faite de façon
équitable ou pas
céder sur un chat mais si le plus d'un
côté ou de l'autre j'en sais rien que ça
non je revois je veux dire moi ce qui me
peine et je le dis je les journées j'ai
jamais caché auprès d'eric aussi c'est
vrai que j'ai
beaucoup eric lecerf et j'ai une
tendresse énorme pour raquel que j'adore
voilà le sait on échange énormément tous
les deux et de l'avoir malheureuse dans
l'émission ça me peine parce que tu sais
que je t'aime beaucoup et je sais que tu
es un grand talent qu'est ce que tu
réponds à eric ben je trouve que tout le
discours sur les insoumis qui sont pas
tolérants c'est par ailleurs un des
thèmes récurrents qui aime beaucoup
grandir eric naulleau mais ça ne résiste
pas à l'épreuve des faits d'abord moi ça
fait des années que je participe à des
émissions de télévision chez r d sont
j'étais avec gilles william goldnadel
je débats avec l'extrême-droite que
geoffroy le jeune je débats avec lui
quand il ya eu thaïs des ce qu'ils font
qui est venu sur notre plateau j'ai
débattu avec elle je lui ai demandé est
ce que vous pouvez dire vive la
république c'était quand même une bonne
prise elle avait pas l avait dit non je
peux pas dire vive la république je fais
le travail je suis quelqu'un de l'assé
libéral par rapport à ça donc là dessus
ça c'est un procès qu'on peut vraiment
pas me faire en revanche je sais
reconnaître la différence entre une
adversité intellectuelle est quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre de rechercher
l'humiliation alors c'est vrai quoi on
avait déjà eu un tous les deux on a tout
de même le mérite et la diriger et
d'ailleurs baisse avait conduit à un
changement de comportement et puis voilà
ça c'est réglé alors moi la semaine
dernière ça faisait déjà trois émissions
que et eric faisait le petit gimmick
hors sujet je moi je me remets en cause
donc j'ai regardé les émissions est en
fait j'étais pas sujet il ya deux
semaines le débat c'est est ce que eric
zemmour est candidat je répondais
j'étais pas au sujet la semaine dernière
on a parlé dès l'école les profondes
angers j'ai parlé des enfants en danger
j'étais pas hors sujet donc c'est cette
façon de me dire draka drak est juste je
dois dire animer cette émission btp
c'est extrêmement compliqué ah oui parce
que il ya dit énormément d'intervenants
serré vous marchez énormément dessus et
c'est vrai que parfois si il n'ya pas de
discipline ça devient catastrophique
l'émission mais juste le garant de la
discipline j'ai trop d'émissions sérique
moi moi je trouve que j'apprécie je
trouve que ces échanges agressif et
cetera nuisent à la qualité des missions
nous font sans doute perdre des
téléspectateurs
franchement je moi je trouve ça assez
nul alors évidemment moi je me quand je
me sens humilié je rends les coûts et
des fois c'est spectaculaire mais ça
m'amuse absolument pas j'ai absolument
pas le goût le goût de ça ce que
j'aimerais moi ce que j'aime c'est la
compétition des idées l'adversaire quel
fondement des liens parfois que vous
faites c'est vrai que vous marchez
beaucoup sur les autres voilà dans le
débat et c'est vrai que c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on vous a pris aussi c'est ce
que disait fiona pour vos qualités aussi
voilà parce que mais parfois c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué pour les autres
salariés avec des animateurs très
professionnelle qu'ils étaient capables
par exemple avec un regard ou un petit
geste de me dire à quel thé trop longue
et c'est là là c'est pas le cas là c'est
qu'elle recherche l'homme en direct
n'est pas encore directement
6-6 on dirait que j'ai déjà fait du
dirait bien sûr j'ai fait beaucoup
beaucoup de chaînes d'info etc c'est
toujours du direct mais là c'est pas le
cas là là éric il adopte la posture de
lentilles mélenchon et d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui avait conduit parce que moi j'ai
relu ton livre là où tu racontes la
fameuse l'éviction d'eric naulleau de la
mutation ya eu l'émission la france a un
sourire et que c'était une discussion
qui avait eu entre jean luc mélenchon et
toitures à propos de la pertinence de la
présence d'eric sur le plateau et vous
en aviez conclu tous les deux parce que
s'il n'est pas pertinent sur la sueur
jaulin comme avait dit je le dis voilà
et moi je les ai compris ça je te le dis
mammeri que c'est vrai que eric il est
il et il a compris le truc s'il était
très peiné à ne pas être là mais
jean-luc mélenchon m'avait dit je ne
serai pas bon je serai moins bon si éric
parce que je vais me sentir moins à
l'aise voilà à toi de voir voilà mais
c'est vrai que je n'aime pas c'est ce
qui m'avait dit jean luc einaudi qui
serait moins à l'aise s'il ya des
sites qu'il y aurait une intensité et sa
pour lire l émission et cqfd mais
pourquoi ça tranquillement jusqu'à ce
que je comprends pas ça moi j'adore
débattra et craque elle est franchement
je pense qu'on a un duo de débat il me
semble intéressant tellement on est
opposé sur le fond il ya beaucoup de
respect et donc je comprends pas
pourquoi vous vous expliquer pas simple
et non bio que de régler des comptes sur
les réseaux sociaux mais les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'après derrière ces
recommandations bâtisse un faux pas leur
jeter la pierre je sais comment ça se
passe on est énervé on rentre chez soi
et surtout je vous dire comment ça se
passe après l'émission sectera qu'elles
rendent chez elle elle voit plein de
tweets lui disant ah oui c'est
inadmissible comment tu te séparer comme
ça il ya des potes qui lui envoient des
sms eric pareil il rentre chez lui y
voit des poteaux lala raquel garrido
c'est insupportable pourquoi tu la
gardes je sais comment va se passer et
là on se chauffe et on dit tiens moi
aussi je vais mettre un tweet parce que
je passe pour un con je passe pour une
conne chez exactement comment ça se
passe et là où mais un tweet et après
parfois on peut le regretter ou pas mais
c'est vrai voilà on sait comment ça se
passe mais c'est que derrière vous lisez
les réactions vous avez des sms de potes
des sms de votre famille et c'est
forcément réagissent et je me pose
quelques questions comment se fait-il
qu'ils niaient qu avec raquel garrido
qu'il y ait des problèmes avec moi ça se
passe très bien avec les autres
chroniqueurs c'est quand même étrange
comment se fait-il qu'ils n'y ait de
problème pour jean luc mélenchon qu'avec
moi comment se fait-il que nier qu'à moi
qu eric coquerel qui représentait la
france insoumise a lancé une fac news
quand même qu'ils étaient assez
phénoménal en disant que j'étais que je
prenais la théorie du grand emplacement
là je me suis opposé 20 fois comment se
fait-il que toi sur ce même plateau il
n'y a qu'à moi qui ai balancé une autre
fête news en disant que en effet la
nouvelle de mon éviction c'est moi qui
l'avait balancé au parisien on a trouvé
qu'il avait balancé depuis comment se
fait-il oui comment se fait-il que l'on
fasse tout un cas de ton opinion alors
que tu est ultra-minoritaire quelle est
cette tyrannie de la minorité on devrait
prendre ton avis comme quelque chose de
très important moi je le prends en
compte en tant que tel mais pourquoi est
ce qu'il est plus important que la vie
de dix autres chroniqueurs ça je ne
comprends pas ils sont ravis en général
de la manière dont ça se passe
simplement cyril et animateur peut-être
qui comprend mieux ce que je dis que toi
le temps de parole d'une émission divisé
par le nombre d'intervenants c'est très
faible je suis obligé à un moment
d'interrompre soit quand tu es trop long
ce qui arrive souvent soit quand tu leur
sujet ce qui t'arrive aussi souvent
c'est pas le plaisir de jouer les pères
fouettards c'est juste que j'ai une
émission à faire marché animé maintenant
si tu veux nommer sa misogynie ce qui
est quand même grotesque zemmour isme
serait grotesque et ma chronique puisque
tu change de version toutes les semaines
je te laisse ces qualificatifs messana
bus personne excuse moi ça va bus perso
rigide moi ce qui me gêne chez raquel
c'est que pratiquement vous daignez à
eric naulleau le droit d'être animateur
mais ça moi ça me choque profondément
parce que si jamais dit ça n'en pas non
mais ce que je ressens c'est qu'en fait
ça vous j'aime qui l'animent voudrait
que ce soit cyril mais quand on est
chroniqueur s'est pas à vous de choisir
et s'il a été choisi c'est qu'il est
tout à fait pertinent maintenant eric je
trouve quand même à chaque fois que vous
intervenez quand vous interrogez ou
presque haranguer raquel je trouve que
vous oubliez que c'est lundi du raquel
garrido et vous voyez on est uniquement
la représentante de la france un seau et
moi ce qui me gêne mais je vous le dis
ce qui me gêne en gardant parfois
l'émission c'est que j'ai l'impression
que quand vous la clash et c'est parra
qu'elle met ses veaux inimitiés non plus
connu pour la france insoumise qui
rejaillissent non pas du tout être bien
même pas que vous pouvez faire verser
mon avis pas du tout alors aujourd'hui
on va priver existe en elle-même ce qui
est vrai c'est que c'est vrai que cette
histoire ça arrange parce que je voulais
dit voilà je suis jeu j'adore cette
émission eric irak elles sont vraiment
d'aider des amis voilà et c'est vrai que
tout ça me peine un peu parce que
j'aimerais que vous puissiez robes trop
travailler ensemble raquel est ce que
toi tu te verrai revenir dans btp avec
eric ou pour l'instant non bah écoute ce
soir la production a proposé que y ait
cet échange
moi j'accepte parce que et par amitié
vraiment par vraiment par amitié avec ça
avec cette émission avec toi parce que
je suis attachée moi j'aime beaucoup
balance tant postes notamment pour
l'instant pas comme c'était avant je
paye a permis à plein des choses qui
vont arriver dans balance toi je vous le
dis voilà avec eric qui sera là aussi je
vais faire aussi des premières parties
de soirée eric fraj deuxième partie de
soirée aussi un moment aussi parce que
va avoir énormément de très gros
rendez-vous avec balances ton post donc
forcément l'émission va arriver en force
là sur la la la la le deuxième semestre
a pas de premier semestre dane et 2022
alors moi de ce que j'ai entendu ce soir
je suis pas rassuré du tout vu qu
évidemment le problème c'est moi qui ne
comprend pas après quand je dis que pour
une femme sur un plateau surtout quand
on veut parler de choses sérieuses
politique et qu'on nous on nous dit t'as
rien compris c'est toujours un peu le
même type de d'arguments c'est à dire en
fait est un peu trop bête pour
comprendre et vous vous dites est
supportable bah c'est le sous-entendant
quand tu dis tu ne comprends pas oui
quand tu me dis tu ne comprends pas ça
veut dire que tu lorsque tu ne voulais
pas passer la nuit tu ne veux pas qu'on
prend donc
cqfd alors on dira que les accusations
misogynie sont exagérées etc mais moi je
vous invite à analyser les images une un
plateau il ya dix hommes une femme de
femmes l'eia ça donne lieu à des trucs à
agressif viriliste on se lève pour pour
menacer taper quelqu'un qui fait ça en
fait est ce qu'une femme est ce que vous
avez déjà vu une femme dans un débat
politique un débat d'idées se lever et
dire un autre invité à métier retire ça
sinon ça va mal se passer sinon ça va se
régler il ya quelque chose de toxiques
en fait notamment pour les femmes et moi
je vous le donne je vous le dis je suis
pas du genre à proférer des accusations
de misogynie gratuitement oui mais c'est
démago que tu dis que quand on te dit ce
que tu dis est idiot peut-être à c'est
parce que je suis une femme non c'est
pas mais le dieu dit
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît et ric
et rac est il nous reste quelques
minutes aujourd'hui éric toi est ce que
tu as envie de retravailler craquer mais
moi j'ai envie de retravailler avec tous
les chroniqueurs d'accord étaient
présents dans l'une ou l'autre des
émissions que j'ai animée je n'ai jamais
demandé l'éviction de quiconque raquel
est évidemment la bienvenue et
simplement je rappelle quelques règles
de base si ici rappeler quelques règles
de base c'est être misogyne bas je
regrette c'est que je suis misogyne mais
est ce que toi tu es capable de mettre
de côté le fait que tu es un militant
anti mélenchon vraiment je suis pas en
1800 milles regarder n'importe qui qui
regarde tes twitté et ton expression en
général
peut le constater tu as dit dans le
journal libération que effectivement
entre mélenchon et zemmour tu vois de
régine et moore j'ai donc fait personne
ne m'a obligé à dire sarron
j'imaginerais quand
d'autres personnes d'autres animateurs
en france qu'ils auraient leur petite
idée de ce qu'ils voient très dans cette
configuration ils ne le disent pas dans
ce journal ce qui fait que quand tu
arrives comme animateur tu charries ça
cette détestation de mélenchon et cette
adhésion à zemmour c'est un problème
pour l'équilibré jours ils ont lâché pas
d'accord
on débattre commence juste juste
raquette et à quels éléments devaient
être respectés tu es respecter
simplement pour l'instant je ne suis pas
resté chez le monde malheureusement tu
voteras du tout on colle je pas respecté
les
règles du débat je regrette c'est ça le
problème mais là c'est pas juste que toi
tu dis est que c est lors les règles du
débat c'est de vous paraissez voulait
l'échanger à partir dans autre chose
voilà c'est tout après à partir de là
tout va bien soit je pense que vous
pouvez reste que ces deux règles c'est
tout eric mon travail comme les villes
d'abidjan sera très très bon tu m'a
coupé il ya deux semaines j'étais en
train de remonter l'allée ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est bon ça
et
deux fois long et il en reste encore
allez-y raquel alessi regarde les
irakiens les irakiens gentil je sais pas
qui
prescrit la chérie hier j'ai regardé les
émissions parce qu'évidemment bas
rhinois est une mine où les rues et
surtout c'est bien ce premier du court
quand on nous dit des choses on se remet
en cause personnellement
cette capacité de se remettre en cause
là je la sens pas ya deux semaines le
débat s'était excuse zemmour peut gagner
la présidentielle j'ai commencé à
prendre la parole pour répondre non à
cette question j'ai commencé à expliquer
que zemmour était le représentant d'un
courant anti sémite français et j'ai été
coupé en disant hors sujet je n'étais
pas hors sujet j'invite tout le monde à
voir et à la prod alors je te rappelles
toi qu'est-ce qu'une eau et non à la
date et ça c'est pas bon on aurait su le
mieux traquer ce qu'elle est ce que tu
veux pas essayer semaine prochaine avec
eric vous faites une émission voyez
comment ça se passe si on refait point
tous les trois ensemble dans mon bureau
après au moins c'est oui j'ai déjà tout
d'une burqa non mais tu
te la joues à l'étoile la chanteuse
chante et d'aujourd'hui
holloway donc voila moi donc savoir ja
pardonnez moi mais il ya meilhat méga
méprise moi je suis pas là pour faire un
spectacle je viens avec mes tripes
fumantes je milite pour des idées j'y
crois aussi fait de la télé pour ça donc
si je suis là pour me faire humilier
alors si c'est pas la classe yono là à
la bouche médiation les chinois zhu min
il faut y aller
ap new york elle alors ces mêmes
personnes qui est harcelée à qui on
demande
parce que et rika d'airy
dans l'émission la soupe à son avis pour
venir à l'école animateur d'émissions et
15 ans qu'on a les îles à l'appel de
recherches auxquelles a les idées je
suis si j'aimerais de faire ce que
j'aime oui mais
foulard est une bête de foire
d'empoigné des mots qui correspondent à
la situation il n'y a pas d' humiliation
c'est fait ou ce soit une question
pourquoi autour d'une table avec avec
toi qui me verrai je prends pas les
chéris je suis prêt à travailler avec
toi répond la réponse
est oui voila je veux que ça soit
bien ben oui mais quid des reçus a
décidé de la tuer dans la butte pouvoir
doit y aller